how someone can get in touch with you
with your team with Mark Zuckerberg with
a lone mask with other people how do
small people can reach by asking okay
the problem is the answer is no 14,000
out of 14001 times that's it
you got your prospective happy don't you
want to be happy
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the very
first episode of the producing of the
tivity show I'm great I'm really cool
can really believe we are here but at
the same time I do believe we are here
because I believe everyone is capable of
pretty much everything and it's one of
the things that you you preach if we may
use this word which is amazing so I
especially I apologize you for jumping
in so early in your horse podcast
especially especially when people are
self aware mmm you know I think I do
think people are capable dramatically
more than they expect but you know
there's you know listen I could be a
dramatically BETT bigger and better
singer than I am right now which isn't
zero hmm but there's also a very fine
line of extending yourself and then
bleeding into delusion there there is no
scenario where I'm gonna be Frank
Sinatra or Beyonce yeah and so I think
one of the things that I worry about
especially in my field of
entrepreneurship do I think that most
people can replicate their salary at a
job that they hate by starting an online
business and over a seven-year period
make the same amount of money talking
about or producing content or selling
things around skiing or Jam making or
shoes than they did as being a miserable
clerk at a retail store yes I do do I
think most people are capable of making
a million dollars a year running a
business no I do not and I think that's
in a very it's a where I think these
debates become too black and white and
some people like oh it's just about
mindset and positivity and you can do it
and everybody's a hater and a troll or
the reverse where people like all these
people are full of [ __ ] they're selling
them [ __ ] and snake oil the reason
that is and the reason I wrote crush it
if you ever really really read it I
believe in passion and optimism and
pushing yourself but I
disproportionately believe in
practicality patience and hard work too
and they seem to be at odds with each
other
exactly
like cool you're about to tell stories
of raising your hand
d-roc we choose you you filmed me it
blew you up this that the other thing
but it also you persevered you you
worked very hard you you got a lot of
nose I don't even remember when it meant
the preparation they've been a conductor
of course preparation look preparation
you know what's funny
opportunity meets preparation that's
something a lot of people talk about
I'll tell you what I believe in I
believe that there's so much [ __ ]
opportunity at all times that it's
actually preparation everybody's [ __ ]
prepared finds their opportunity yeah so
so sure I believe in it
but here's what I actually believe in
opportunity is abundant mm-hmm we live
in a world that has unlimited
opportunity especially if you're willing
to look for it looking for it is
predicated on the fact that you put in
the work you put in the work because you
knew that you were gonna go look for it
so I believe in preparation preparation
preparation because I just believe that
opportunity is almost like oxygen it's
everywhere
always and some opportunities are bigger
than others but preparation man people
don't do people convince themselves
before they start that the world is
unjust or they can't there's things are
[ __ ] up they complain they'd well they
say no before they say yes and of course
look if you say no it's already over
like a litter if you wake up and say
it's not gonna happen for me it's
already over you you might as well not
try exactly you know there isn't I
started this way and I went there
because currently we are in Warsaw
Poland mm-hmm just before you go on the
main stage and deliver your keynote yeah
and again what connects us especially
here is that you were born in Belarus
that's right if we may say that we have
your mom here with us and she kindly you
know came over just to see the this area
for a little bit yes and uh I'm from
Poland I moved to the UK at ten years
ago yes kind of similar story yes why I
said that opportunity meets preparation
and if you believe it and how is that
I've got so many questions and and
how I did it what happened and how to do
it so this is kind of one of the Chris
not want to ask you because possibly on
my based on my story but I don't want
that to come from my ego I want that to
come from a source where I want to teach
someone something so we can deliver
content how people now we have like 800
people in the room how someone can get
in touch with you with your team with
Mark Zuckerberg with our mask with other
people how do small people can reach by
asking ok the problem is the answer is
no 14,000 out of 14001 times that's it
but I'm more than happy to spend the
next seven minutes explaining that but I
think most logical people with any basic
education understand that's it
I mean 9,000 people asked to do
something with me in the last two hours
on direct message email and Twitter and
they offered to pay you to do something
Oh
first of all let's talk about it let's
break it down actually let's go there
for once 92% of those people asked in a
[ __ ] way where they made it seem
like they're trying to do something for
me but it's actually for them mm-hmm my
favorite people who are gonna pick me up
at the airport and drive me to the hotel
yeah yeah you mean I'm gonna fly 9 hours
I need 30 minutes to myself to catch up
but what you really want to do is pitch
me your business or get something out of
me or take a picture with me so you can
leverage it on social media for just
driving me people are selfish mm-hmm the
reason 14,000 at a 14001 get an O is
because of the 14,000 ask Mark Cuban to
do something for him or her of the
14,000 people that ask Sara Blakely or
Beth Comstock for their time 13850 four
of them are selfish as [ __ ] could give a
[ __ ] about Mark Cuban Sara Blakely or
Beth Comstock and wants something for
themselves
so they're out because I promise you
this anybody at the top can smell it
from a mile away
sure that's a very good answer wait
okay next week or sometime I want to
carry on with the mind I have a lot of
questions well recently over the last
few days in weeks
when people follow me let me jump back I
run it go on all right no it's an
important because I've never really
expanded on it you're asking one of the
most successful people in what you
aspire to whether it's sport or
education or medicine or
entrepreneurship you're asking somebody
who it's only asset is time yes it is
remarkable to me that I've achieved
success to the place where I'd much
rather write a $50,000 check to charity
than give an hour to that charity of my
time something I could have never
imagined a decade ago time is the
number-one asset I don't I don't like
this is the most ha most fun with my mom
in the last year I like time there is no
time there's no time there's no even
time on this trip we'd spend no time
together so so people are asking for
time and access and a cosign and money
and to leverage that person for fame the
reason everybody gets an O is because
they're greedy and they're trying to
take how to do it the right way give
without expectation and and that end or
get lucky like when I say lucky the the
odds of one in 14,000 chance I would
argue is luck other people say it wasn't
luck you actually took the chance to
email your write I talked about
perseverance a lot of people email me
once a day yeah because I talked so much
about perseverance but I can see the
evil in their approach so it has no
chance the merit of it all look let's be
very transparent this is what's great
about me I forget everything that isn't
great but I don't recall what but I
definitely recall that even in our
relationship there was something as it
started I don't remember exactly what
happened but I remember you being
concerned that maybe you overstepped it
with yeah I don't remember is what it
was there was some but I know it was
wrong yes like I know that it wasn't the
right move the good news was I had good
intention but I didn't know and and and
what it was was I don't recall but if
you're asking me to recall it was just
it happens to everybody it's a lack of
patience it's a it's a you're on to
something and you want to take the next
step what's the right timing to build on
a relationship the reason I have so many
fancy friends and associates is I don't
want anything from them ever and will
never ask them for anything thus I have
the unlimited leverage the reason
so many people better that were above me
continue to be above me and the scoring
of like fame or wealth or access or
power the reason it always drawn to me
always and forever is I don't want
anything from nobody always forever the
end there is no relationship there's no
friendship there's no meeting that I
want because I want something out of
them as a matter of fact with the
fanciest PIPA you know I even think
about whether got I've got I'm not gonna
name drop but I think about the people
that I would score as like they're
further along in the Q score of it all I
go into those meetings
disproportionately trying to give them
as much as I have for their Deneuve yes
what I mean yeah further than me I just
try to go there and deeply over deliver
on what I bring to them literally ask
for nothing and [ __ ] leave I have an
advantage because I have a skill right
now in something that's very important
which is modern-day communication that
matters for everybody from you know
number one to number one seven point
seven billions so I have something to
give as well I was a very good
celebration I said something the other
day I have not been at a meeting or an
event where I have not said a word in 15
years and it happened the other day I
was at a meeting with Eric Schmidt a
chairman of Google at Google with the
president of Cuba
and yeah so I was with the president of
Cuba and and we having this meeting with
like 10 people and I had nothing that I
had nothing to add to the conversation
in the situation that Cuba's in right
now with the current administration in
America where the embargoes back kind of
on and this anonymous listening and ear
being being another Twitter we're
talking I wanted to tell the story of my
mom writing a book reporter when she was
a kid about cube or Fidel Castro I had
it in my mind what was the appropriate
thing to say but it was so important to
me that if you talk or you do something
you have something to bring I 99.99999
percent of the time have that and put
myself in a position to do that this was
I was very excited
leaving that leaving Google the other
day I was like wow I really live by my
thesis I didn't say anything I didn't
need the attention I feel like I always
needed
I think that if that's what I'm about
but I realized yes but not more than I
don't want to talk for the sake of
talking I don't need to sell hear myself
speak I love it I love myself I love
hearing myself speak I love myself I
love hearing myself speak because I have
something to say
I value to bring I know it's bringing
value to the other person on this
podcast in this room on that stage I
knew that I had nothing of value to say
in that meeting the other day other than
trying to make myself look good to the
Cuban delegate which could have then led
to me doing some business there in the
future that was selfish that didn't
allow me to speak that's why everybody
gets a no they don't have the ability to
do that because on the way up they're
trying to grab it something yeah that's
a very good answer and I've learned a
lot over the last few years I appreciate
that thank you we'd answer another one
question please sure
your podcast hahaha oh as well yeah what
do you think it's at what point a lot of
people that follow you or a lot of
business people they started the
freelancers in any field whether it's
right or FileMaker whatever they started
the freelancer usually with a part-time
full-time job then at what point if the
business going okay okay okay should
they either stay a freelancer or become
a freelancer with a micro freelancing
team or get full timers and open
businesses like you know what I mean of
course I know you mean um there's a lot
of answers to that question then we
started this I don't know we do we start
this with Sofia
we started this podcast with
self-awareness mm-hmm the answer is
depending on your situation
mm-hmm if you're 21 and you have no
expenses and you're living at home you
have to go high-risk as soon as you see
any blood in the water you go if I'm 21
and I'm at home and I have no expenses
and and I'm making 47 thousand euros
pounds dollars doing something I don't
love but I want to be a film person and
the first person pays me $1,500 or $1
forever and it works and it went well
and she the boss of this candy store
says I'm gonna tell my
about you I may jump right away hmm I
don't have any concerns if I'm 42 years
old and I have three kids and a mortgage
and I'm $100,000 in debt because I went
to college in America and didn't get me
a good job and I'm an accountant and I
make 137 thousand a year which basically
pays for my overhead roughly because I
bought a house bigger than I needed
about a car bigger than I needed this
cliche American and somebody pays me
$1,500 and they're like I'm gonna tell
my friends I'm gonna give up Netflix and
my video games and my weekends to
eventually get that to 60 or 70 or 80 or
90 thousand a year before I say okay now
I'm at 90 137 if I actually went all-in
I can close the gap on that 57,000 now
I'm gonna make the jump because I've
three [ __ ] kids on mortgage and debt
every piece of my advice is
circumstantial what makes me vulnerable
in producing pieces of content on the
Internet is it lacks contexts for every
individual the reason I produce so much
content is the reason a piece of content
may hit somebody different this time
next time is because even the same
person's life changes yesterday Aaron is
25 and single and living at home
tomorrow he meets Sheila falls in love
and you know a million things could
happen Sheila could be making a million
dollars a year different life Sheila
could be making no money but he loves
her so much and she wants to buy
handbags every day and now he has a
bigger you know financial problems
Sheila wants to be his partner she like
he wants to buy handbags it's not cliche
[ __ ] it's life it's contextual and
that's why the answer to your question
is a million [ __ ] things but you jump
when you can afford to drown you jump
when you can afford to drown what I mean
by that is when you jump into the pool
you have to know that you've never swam
before and you might drown and you have
to be able to do that when you can and a
21 living at home you can yeah cuz you
can go back and get a job you have no
overhead right but at 43 with three kids
you might not want to yeah and by the
way or you might you might have such a
supportive spouse Sheila Aaron's the
stay home dad Sheila's making the 140
and Sheila talks to Aaron says Aaron I'm
gonna die if I don't jump I'm 43 and if
I don't jump now I'm gonna be 62 and
regretted my whole life so I'm gonna
jump and if I fail and the economy
collapses that I can't get a job we may
have to sell this home we may have to
move in with our parents in Florida but
I have to do that and take the loss in
front of everybody's eyes that were
losers and we [ __ ] up because I know
myself and I know if I don't jump now
I'm gonna be miserable for 40 years that
I was a accountant for my whole life so
you know these are very important
conversations these are layered
conversations these are deep way deeper
than what people talk about and the
reason I always talk about lately
because I finally [ __ ] said oh [ __ ]
the reason I want everybody to live the
way I do which is do not care what other
people think once you go there you're
willing to jump you're willing to drown
you're willing to move in with your 80
year old parents and look like losers
with your kids because you just don't
care I mean it's so crazy to me I will
believe it not a person maybe maybe
outside my mom but it's even difficult
to what I'm about to say is even
difficult to fully believe it's crazy to
me that where I am at this moment in my
life that the thought of making 84 bad
mistakes in a row that caused me to have
to move in with my parents and have my
kids live and like like to think about
that the level of unbelievable bad
decisions that make no sense to get me
to that place it's scary to me how much
that doesn't like I basically go into
like well it's cozy at my parents house
like like it'll be cool that my kids get
to spend that kind of time with Gramps
like it's unbelievable to me because
here's what will happen what will happen
is I will take an enormous amount of
beating in the public like what a
[ __ ] loser he thought he was so cool
he was telling everybody else to do it
and he [ __ ] collapsed look at him and
all the people that don't like me cuz
I'm suffocating their [ __ ] will they
like see and all my fans will be
devastated because their friends who
don't
maybe like say you [ __ ] thought that
guy was special he's such a [ __ ]
loser
he lost everything he lives with his
parents here's the thing with me
I just won't hear it I'll know it's
happening I'll hear it meaning I'll read
it I'll hear it but it won't penetrate
you will let that to get into you
it just won't control me what will
happen is I'll spend a good amount of
time reconciling like how could this
thing even happened and then I would go
back out there and [ __ ] win again oh
my god someone stuff I'm like look I
don't know I want to I apologize cuz I
gotta get these questions and I know we
have other things but this is very
important talk because this is deeper in
my thesis that I normally go because I
want to give you something else for your
first podcast to help you this is me
trying to help you this is Huizar very
nuanced aspects to what I'm talking
about that people don't talk about the
reason people aren't letting themselves
get happy is because they value other
people's opinions more than they value
their happiness
they literally value their parents their
siblings their best friends and
society's opinion more than their own
happiness they value like you live your
life that you value other people's
opinions more than being happy that's
[ __ ] crazy when you think about
that's truly that is what the 99% of our
world is thinking people don't get
divorces because they're worried about
what people think that they got divorced
and like they'll judge people navigate
their life on people's judgement and
what's interesting to me about people is
in certain ways they're okay with being
judged and in other ways they're not in
this category I'm okay but in that one
I'm not in business I'm okay but in
personal life no in relationships I am
but not in marriage in what like and so
like if you can get to a place where no
where you become unstoppable um I feel
like I'm so strong and unstoppable
because every day every year every
minute every decade I've been able to
chip away at more insecurities and make
them strengths and many of those people
are unhappy yes yes and there was a
reason why letting somebody else dictate
your life his immediate unhappiness
mm-hmm you're not in control and that
brings me to very last topic or a
question there was a reason
Podcast and project is called producing
positivity as well as my production
company because I truly believe and you
had a huge influence on that that
whatever we do if we can share good
things and positivity and help someone
else that's a good thing so let's focus
on that and I know you talk about
positive so much but there are certain
topics that needs to be repeated almost
every day what can a person do that is
dwelling we talk in a car about the
situation that happened recently and
like I said like let's not talk about
Ali said let's stop the wedding guess
there's no point we can't really control
that we can just do the best of what we
can out of it so if there are some ones
sitting listening and whether this
person comes from a very poor family
Poland Belarus whether there is an
alcohol or drugs problem or money or
maybe this guy is a guy from California
who is a lot of it but it's still
unhappy unhappy what to do every day how
to build how to build consistency yeah I
think there's a couple things that stand
out to me that are practical first of
all it's been really interesting so many
people get upset with me when I talk
about nobody cares about your feelings
because I Gary there's so much somebody
to me today Gary there's so much
injustice in the world how can you say
that to them [ __ ] you I'm like yeah
that's cool you're right
there's injustice but there's injustice
for everybody like meaning like
everybody's got a [ __ ] problem like
you just don't know it
you just think the person with the
Mercedes doesn't have a problem you
don't realize that their husband is
beating them or or infidelity or their
mom hates them and there's a the other
judgment so a couple things
for some people it's worked because I
pushed to them that nobody cares nobody
cares about your problems because they
have their own problems and that's work
for some people like literally some
people have emailed me they're like my
life has changed because you pounded to
me that nobody gives a [ __ ]
nobody cares so I was like [ __ ] if
that's true the hell am i complaining
for and all of a sudden I stop
complaining and all of a sudden that
[ __ ] started happening so that works the
other thing that I think works the most
the most I think people have to drop
people in their lives
I really do I think people have to drop
negativity other lives I think people
need to get divorced I think people need
to stop talking to their parents I think
people need to I think kids need to stop
talking to their folks folks to their
kids like I just don't know what else to
tell you it's all very do you think
dropping people is more important or as
important as being around these five
people that everyone talks about like
dropping the bad guys is more important
than going towards the good ones or not
I mean I think I think they work here
and then here about 50/50 of course I
think when you drop you know I think I
think look being around positivity and
optimism and offense and practicality
and ethics and good it always makes you
better but being around negativity and
dragging down always makes you worse so
to me it's net score you want it you
know you don't like what I'm saying and
you don't want to drop your your dad or
mom or or wife or husband fine then go
out and find seven positive friends and
reallocate your time when I say drop
drop comes in many forms drop comes in
divorce drop comes in maybe you
shouldn't hang out with them every hour
drop comes in with spending time with
positive friends you know and listen
there's so many cliche things this is so
basic there's only 33 things 19 things
eight things that are happening in life
negative people latch on to positive
people and try to seclude them from the
world because that's their little energy
in work I see it every day in life I see
it every day it's just what it is so a
positive end look I can be positive for
everybody my flaw my vulnerability is I
try to take on all emotional
responsibility for everybody and
everything and it's what but I have so
much to give that it allows me to also
control every situation so like we all
have it it's all obvious but look if
you're unhappy it's because you're
spending too much time with unhappy
people and by the way sometimes you're
the unhappy person and and that person
ends up lonely every time always the end
and I love that I love that bad people
end up lonely even people that are close
to me I love it
I think it's right it's how life should
be it's merit it plays out bad can only
win for a certain period of time I
genuinely believe that
it's proven otherwise humans wouldn't be
here I love how people are not smart
guys if bad wins it would have been over
a long time ago Hitler would have won
Ganga's Kong would have won the Ebola
would have wiped us out bombs would have
been dropped we've had atomic bombs for
70 years we have had the ability to wipe
out the world for 70 years why hasn't it
happened humans are and it's what pisses
me off about terrorism I hate the
American propaganda of terrorism that
everybody buys into if terrorism was
real the way that it's sold every day in
London Paris in New York people would
take a van and drive into Times Square
and around Buckingham Palace and kill 30
people you can't stop it my mom is
here's the London you know train was
searched for security they keep checking
our passport she doesn't travel like she
says to me oh I like this I like it I
was I was laughing I'm like mom they're
not saving you what's the nobody's
stopping anything what's saving you is
there's just not that much bad and for
the couple that are bad it's easy to
stop them and occasionally they get
lucky you're far more likely to die
because somebody drinks and drives or
texts and drives than you are a
terrorist [ __ ] it's just this bad
thing the terrorists are going up in
media and brand aliens no no terrorists
are good at branding that's another
conversation it's a it's see
conversation it's branding sorry guys
your negativity is a very easy sale
it's called insurance no kind of good
business insurances your house is gonna
go on fire so buy this it's true how
much money is made selling fear fear is
very easy so let's focus on positivity
for me and that's where all the good
stuff is happening so why it's you know
fear is a son of a [ __ ] negativity is a
son of a [ __ ] but it's only slightly
beaten by positivity and that's why this
is all playing out and it's very basic
but and I want to say this delusion is a
big mistake
the reason and I don't know anything
about this secret but one of the secret
got big because Oprah put it on I didn't
read it obviously cuz I don't read but
what was interesting to me was there was
people that interpreted as like if I sit
on my couch and I think that it will all
all get a million dollars that they
literally thought that that's how it
worked
this is positivity only equalled by
practicality yes practicality is
everything yet the work I wish people it
the biggest reason I rock and I started
daily be I only started daily be so
there was no confusion nobody believes
me to this day nobody believes how hard
I work and I show you and they still try
to make for tenants not real and you're
we sure started that ten years ago yes
just to show that very we did I wish I
wish people realize how little like I
wish people saw every day of my twenties
on a Saturday was in a liquor store I
wish their mommies nothing I wish people
knew because it's so easy to point now
and say you're lucky or whatever when
you don't know the story you don't know
the story the biggest reason I don't
judge anybody else is cuz I'm judged so
much Gary thank you very very much
that's it yeah that's right
I can I can we can talk for hours
appreciated I appreciate that thank you
very local yeah
don't know what to say is just it's
awesome
positive thank you appreciate big part
of my life to you literally thank you
you got it
[Applause]
[Music]